il fut un temps où le centre st-pierre
était l'un des fleurons du commerce
bisontin une galerie marchande ultra
moderne des années 70 dont les cellules
s'arrachaient à prix d'or aujourd'hui il
ne reste plus qu'une dizaine
d'enseignants dans le bâtiment
vieillissant des commerces dont les
propriétaires viennent d'apprendre
qu'ils avaient trois semaines pour se
mettre aux normes anti incendie sous
peine de fermeture administrative
on va clôturer 20 ans de ma vie moi je
veux la paix 99
sans nous prévenir san mames
effectivement je pense d'ailleurs des
délais légaux pour prévenir
effectivement les gens qu effectivement
il va y avoir une fermeture et dont le
cac puisse se mettre en conformité mais
en fait la réalité est qu'on a ressoudé
courrier hier au printemps dernier comme
elle le fait depuis plusieurs années la
commission de sécurité a émis un avis
défavorable à l'accueil du public au
centre st-pierre a sorti cette fois
d'une obligation de travaux sous six
mois une information qui n'auraient pas
été relayées aux commerçants par leur
syndic
si on ferme administrativement je
pourrais continuer à travailler mais je
peux plus apte à accueillir du public
donc faut que je voie comment ça peut se
passer alors soit j'aime est de très tôt
devant la porte et puis je vais faire de
la vente à emporter et je vais continuer
à travailler dans mon local comme je le
fais sans accueillir de public si j'en
ai la possibilité et puis après je
remets en groupement local de toute
façon c'est purement et simplement
l'arrêt de mort de la société pour être
en conformité avec les normes de
sécurité les commerçants vont devoir
installer des panneaux pare feu dans
leurs locaux d'ici trois semaines des
travaux pour lesquels il faut une
autorisation qui peut prendre plusieurs
mois difficile dans ces conditions
d'imaginer comment ils vont éviter la
fermeture il a bien été précisé qu'on
laissait un délai supplémentaire de
façon à ce que chacun puisse s'effectuer
prendre les mesures
qu'ont laissé un délai supplémentaire
mais que la prochaine visite qui aurait
lieu donc après les vacances d'été
serait la dernière le syndic de la
galerie marchande n'a pas souhaité nous
expliquer pourquoi les commerçants
n'avaient pas eu cette information
la mairie elle promet d'être indulgente
si les travaux sont réalisés dans les
règles de l'art